let's talk about how lizzo attacks men
for just existing her
her song the truth hurts and I have to
say I used to love this song but I never
really listened to the lyrics and then
it's funny I memorized these lyrics
without even really thinking about what
she was saying what they meant why men
great till they gotta be great I just
took a DNA test and it turns out I'm a
hundred percent that even when I'm
crying crazy yeah I got boy problems
with the human in Me Bling Bling then I
saw them that's the goddess in me you
could have had a bad non-committal
helped you with your career just a
little you're supposed to hold me down
but now you're holding me back and this
is the sound of me not calling you back
so she starts off saying why are men
great until they gotta be great so now
she's on men for just existing